Cancer markers are CA 15, 3, 19, 27, 29, 21.6, and CA 125 is 5.6. Should I feel good about these results?
Well, if your tumor markers are within normal range, you should feel good about those results,
but it partly depends on if this is the first time you've ever had them done,
because to burst anybody's bubble, but if you've never ran tumor markers ever before,
and now you're just running them for the first time in there within normal range,
we don't know how good of a news that is. It's always good news when any labs come back normal.
But we don't know how good news it is if this is the first time they were ever run.
That's why we've always encouraged getting tumor markers done as soon as possible,
because you want to get a baseline of where you're at.
So if in the past your tumor markers were elevated,
whether this is time to celebrate, so anytime you have abnormal labs that come back normal after
a series of treatments, that's how you could objectively measure the efficacy of the care.
So that would be really good news. If you, oh, I never ran these before, these are,
well, in truth, they could have been much higher, and an older range elevated in the past,
or some people with cancer don't show elevated tumor markers. So,
I mean, typically with breast cancer, you're going to be elevated tumor markers more often than not.
But many other cancers don't show elevated tumor markers, but typically with cancer, you would,
with breast cancer, you would, but you always wanted, that's why I look at that plant work.
Why I always recommend getting regular plant work, because you look at it,
you know, how it changes over time, and that's really the most important marker, you know.
If oh my gosh, I have anemia. Well, what was it two months ago?
Oh, here it is. Oh, it was way worse two months ago. Okay, we're about in the right direction.
You're looking at trends, or it was, it was, I didn't have anemia two months ago.
Okay, we're trendy to the wrong direction. We got to figure out why. So,
we do want to look at past markers.